colombia está viviendo una nueva jornada
de paro nacional que prosigue a las
masivas movilizaciones que se celebraron
y que iniciaron el pasado 28 de abril en
en principio en rechazo a la reforma
tributaria el presidente iván duque que
fue retirada por el mandatario
colombiano el pasado domingo sin embargo
como vemos aquí hoy en una de las
principales arterias de la capital
bogotana
bogotá los manifestantes han vuelto a
las calles y es que sus exigencias van
más allá de la reforma tributaria en un
país donde la pandemia que se encuentra
en su tercera ola está afectando
gravemente a sus ciudadanos con el 42
por ciento de los de la población en
situación de pobreza por ello los
manifestantes están hoy aquí en las
calles para exigirle al gobierno mejoras
sociales y también una de las voces que
están resonando es el fin de la
violencia policial y es que los últimos
días hemos visto fuertes enfrentamientos
entre los manifestantes y las fuerzas
del orden público que están reprimiendo
las manifestaciones en su mayoría
pacíficas de forma violenta aún a unos
hechos que han llevado a la condena
internacional diferentes organismos
internacionales han condenado esta
represión contra las marchas pacíficas
si bien el gobierno colombiano ha
abierto una mesa de diálogo los
manifestantes y los convocantes del paro
nacional no se sienten representados y
están hoy aquí en las calles para exigir
unas mejoras sociales y un futuro digno